Traductor: Martina Cano
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Bella.
Dama.
Diosa.
¿O no que soy todo lo que esperaban ver?
Público: ¡Sí!
"Sí", qué mentirosos que son.
Re que en el fondo alguien está:
"Che, no sé si es tan bella... ¿eh?
Yo para diosa del stand up
esperaba un poquito más".
Hay alguien más al fondo diciendo:
"Yo de acá ni la veo, la verdad.
Esperemos al video para decidir, ¿no?"
Bella.
Dama.
Diosa.
Capaz alguien está: "Yo ni siquiera
sé lo que es el stand up".
¿Puede ser? ¿Hay alguien en la sala
que esté en esa condición?
¿Ella? Ella se rio así como...
Lo voy a explicar de manera simplísima,
para que entendamos todos.
El stand up es una manera de hacer humor,
en la que está un comediante
arriba de un escenario,
completamente solo,
frente a un público,
con la intención de hacer reír.
Bella.
Dama.
Diosa.
¿Qué tienen que ver estas categorías, no?
En el stand up, a las mujeres comediantes
nos presentan de esa manera.
Bella.
Dama.
Diosa.
Categorías que no tienen nada que ver
con la capacidad, o no, de hacer reír.
¿No es cierto?
Y categorías que, además, jamás usarían
para presentar a un hombre comediante.
Jamás en un show de stand up
van a escuchar decir:
"Recibimos ahora al más hermoso
comediante de la Argentina".
Jamás. Eso no pasa.
¿Por qué?
Porque vivimos en una sociedad
que todavía es machista.
Y el stand up es, por ende,
todavía machista.
El humor no tiene género.
Sin embargo, aparecen categorías
como el "humor femenino".
El humor es humor. Y punto.
¿No?
Estamos en la Facultad de Derecho y yo
creo que a nadie acá se le ocurriría decir
que una abogada ejerce el
"derecho femenino" por ser mujer.
¿No?
A mí, cuando comencé mi carrera,
un colega me invitó a participar
en un evento solidario.
Yo estaba muy emocionada,
pero hacía chistes sobre sexo.
Entonces lo chequeé antes, le dije:
"Che, ¿vos conocés mi material?
¿Te parece que esto da para
que yo vaya y me presente?"
Me dice: "Sí, tranquila. Es un
evento solidario, chicos de quinto año,
un sábado a la noche. Todo tranqui".
Bárbaro.
Vamos juntos al evento.
Quinientas personas.
Para mí en ese momento era como...
¡Un montón de gente!
Emocionada, esperando.
Sube él al escenario.
Hace chistes de sexo,
dice malas palabras.
Todo genial, la gente súper arriba.
Subo yo al escenario...
Digo la palabra que empieza con "pi"
y termina con "to"
y automáticamente veo las caras
en el público transformarse.
De repente fue como...
hostilidad total.
Yo los veía a todos, vi cómo una señora se
levantaba de su asiento y se iba a quejar.
El mismo compañero
que me había invitado me hacía...
Me bajé prácticamente llorando,
les soy sincera.
Me bajé muy mal del escenario.
Y cuando bajé busqué una explicación
y me encontré a uno de
los organizadores del evento
y me dice: "Sí, el evento es
de los chicos de quinto año,
pero es para que los de primero
viajen a misionar al norte del país".
Yo dije: "Ya está. Es obvio por qué
mi material no funcionó".
Pero, ¿viste cuando peleás con alguien,
que te vas y, al rato, decís:
"Ay, le tendría que haber dicho esto,
esto y esto"?
Me pasó exactamente lo mismo.
Al rato estaba así en mi casa pensando.
Y dije: "Momentito...
Yo viajé dos horas de ida,
dos horas de vuelta,
no cobré un peso,
fui con mi mejor voluntad,
y casi vuelvo apedreada.
Mi colega hizo chistes más subidos
de tono que yo, usó malas palabras,
y no pasó nada".
En ese momento me cayó la ficha:
no era el evento,
no era mi material.
El problema era ser mujer.
El humor no tiene género,
pero el entorno de la comedia
te va a hacer sentir y creer que sí.
El otro día yo le escribí a un productor,
porque me enteré
que había un nuevo lugar
para hacer stand up,
y le escribí para pedirle una fecha,
para decirle que tenía
disponibilidad para actuar.
Me clavó el visto.
Básicamente.
Y yo dije: "Bueno, estará ocupado".
Y después, hablando con otro colega
me dice: "Lo que pasa
es que él tiene un problema
con las mujeres.
Él no invita mujeres a actuar
porque dice que las mujeres
no son graciosas".
Además de tener un prejuicio él,
lo que está haciendo, al ser productor,
es decidir por el público
qué es y qué no es gracioso.
Qué vale la pena
y qué no vale la pena ver.
Voy a contarles ahora un chiste.
¿Están preparados?
Van una rubia y una morocha
caminando por un parque.
De repente, la morocha dice:
"¡Ay, qué asco! ¡Un pájaro muerto!"
Y la rubia dice: "¿Dónde? ¿Dónde?"
Con un poco de delay, ¿no?
¿De qué nos reímos?
Yo estoy convencida de que el camino
a una sociedad más igualitaria
comienza por hacernos preguntas
tan simples como esta.
¿De qué nos reímos?
Ese chiste lo usa Alejandro Angelini,
que es uno de los padres
del stand up en Argentina,
para explicar
la estructura básica del chiste.
Nosotros, en stand up, tenemos:
una premisa y un remate.
¿Qué es una premisa?
Una afirmación de la realidad, ¿sí?
Algo que damos por verdadero
y que el chiste va a confirmar.
¿De qué nos reímos?
De lo tonta que es la rubia buscando
un pájaro muerto en el cielo.
La premisa implícita ahí es el prejuicio:
"las rubias son tontas".
No quiere decir que todos
los chistes sean prejuicios. No.
Pero él lo usa porque le sirve para
explicarlo de manera muy fácil.
Y yo elegí este chiste que él usa
porque también nos sirve para ver
cuántas veces nos reímos
y no nos frenamos a preguntar
de qué nos estamos riendo, ¿no?
Uno se ríe de un chiste y no dice:
"Me río porque..."
Pero está bueno
empezar a tomar consciencia,
porque esto pasa
tanto a nivel del público,
como del comediante.
Los mandatos, los prejuicios, están
tan instalados en nuestro inconsciente
que no los vemos.
Los comediantes,
los comediantes de stand up,
específicamente,
hacemos chistes que son
nuestra visión del mundo,
nuestra opinión sobre ciertos temas.
Y, a veces,
afirmamos cosas que son...
Por lo menos,
polémicas.
Por no decir horrorosas.
Yo estoy haciendo, actualmente,
una investigación
para la cual tomé videos
de mujeres comediantes
y se los mostré a otras mujeres.
Y les pregunté:
"¿Qué te pareció gracioso?
Si es que algo te pareció gracioso, ¿no?
De todos los chistes que vieron,
uno de los que más gracia causó
fue uno que hablaba
sobre esconder el rollo
y decía algo como:
"Escondés el rollo aunque estés
hace 14 años con el mismo hombre".
¿De qué nos reímos en ese caso?
La premisa que sigue vigente,
circulando ahí, es:
"la mujer debe ser flaca, no tener rollos,
o, si los tenés, escondelos".
Pero sigue siendo:
"la mujer debe ser flaca".
Con esto yo no quiero decir
que no hay que hacer chistes
sobre "las mujeres deben ser flacas".
Pero sí que preguntarnos
"¿de qué nos reímos?"
nos sirve para tomar consciencia.
Porque nosotros podemos hacer humor
reforzando estereotipos
o combatiéndolos.
Pero tenemos que tomar consciencia,
si no, la cosa no cambia.
De todas formas, yo pienso que lo peor
que podemos hacer, en este caso,
es juzgar a la comediante
que hace el chiste.
¿Sí?
El feminismo, además de una teoría,
es una práctica.
Y se construye a base
de permitirnos equivocarnos
para replantearnos y cambiar.
Por eso digo:
"El que esté libre de mandatos,
que tire la primera piedra".
Yo soy parte de un show, cuyo nombre
es la traducción literal del stand up
y lo femenino.
Al principio, la verdad,
no reflexionamos mucho sobre esto.
Era el nombre del WhatsApp y quedó.
Era el grupo del WhatsApp.
Bueno, nombre del show.
No nos dimos cuenta, pero,
de repente, terminamos con este logo.
La chica del baño, fucsia,
fondo negro, con el micrófono.
Y, de repente, un día nos dimos cuenta
de que estábamos actuando en calzas,
súper apretadas y brillosas, y tacos.
Y frenamos y dijimos:
"Esto, ¿nos representa?"
Como que tuvimos un ataque de decir:
"Esto no puede ser, esto es terrible".
¿Qué hicimos entonces?
(Risas)
No tuvimos mejor idea que agregarle
un bigote al logo.
Horror de horrores.
Pero, bueno, lo importante
es que, hoy por hoy,
nuestro vestuario, nuestra gráfica,
se adapta un poco más
a lo que somos nosotras.
Pero, sin duda, el primer punto de partida
fue prender el signo de interrogación
y modificar cada vez que la alarma
nos sonora con la respuesta.
Yo, hasta ahora, les hablé de humor
porque es a lo que me dedico.
Pero es importante que nos demos cuenta
de que los estereotipos,
los mandatos, los prejuicios,
los reproducimos, una y otra vez, en todos
los discursos que circulan en la sociedad.
En todos y cada uno de ellos.
Tenemos que tomar consciencia de esto
si realmente queremos cambiarlo.
Yo hoy escuché una publicidad en la radio,
que era de una prepaga y decía así:
"Esperarla por 40 minutos
afuera del probador
te recuerda por qué la elegiste:
lo bueno se hace esperar".
Mi idea es que, en este momento,
transformemos la pregunta
"de qué nos reímos" en
"qué ideas hay detrás de esto".
Esa pregunta es clave.
¿Qué ideas hay detrás de esta publicidad?
Que las mujeres aman ir de shopping.
Que tardan 40 minutos en el shopping.
Que arrastran al hombre a esta situación.
Que los hombres tienen
que aguantar esta situación
porque las mujeres
se tienen que hacer desear.
Que las mujeres tienen que ser
histéricas con los hombres.
Podemos seguir así, reflexionando,
un montón de tiempo
antes de que la prepaga
sea el mensaje inicial.
Esto pasa con las mejores
y las peores intenciones.
Hay publicidades que intentan romper esto.
Que, de repente, te dicen...
Un desodorante, ¿no?
Te dice: "Resaltá la belleza
que hay en vos".
Está partiendo de la premisa
de que la mujer tiene belleza.
En algún lugar del cuerpo
tenés que tener belleza.
Solo tenés que detectar
en qué lugar y resaltarla.
Esto pasa también con
los desodorantes de hombre.
A los hombres no se les exige
que escondan el rollo.
No se les exige que sean
un exponente de belleza,
pero, de repente, una publicidad
de desodorante de hombre
que tiene el eslogan:
"Hasta los ángeles caerán".
¿Qué ideas hay detrás de eso?
Que, si sos un hombre, tu norte tiene
que ser concretar la mayor cantidad
de encuentros sexuales posibles,
porque ese es el ideal masculino.
¿Sí?
Ahora quiero proponerles un juego.
Cuando se vayan de acá,
a lo primero que encuentren en los medios,
ya sea en la tele, en la radio,
en la calle, un afiche, una publicidad,
háganle la pregunta:
"¿qué ideas hay detrás de esto?
Porque esa pregunta nos habilita
a hacer otras preguntas,
simples,
pero que sirven para que nos demos cuenta
de qué hay detrás.
Lo voy a hacer primero yo, con un ejemplo.
Es un juego que a mí me interesa hacer.
No sé si está tan copado, ¿viste?
Porque preguntarse y preguntarse,
a veces, es un poco molesto.
Sino, todos amaríamos
a los niños en la edad del por qué
y eso claramente no pasa.
Yo lo voy a hacer con esta
tapa de revista,
para demostrarles cómo funciona el juego.
Vemos una mujer, con una pollera,
una aspiradora, una camisa.
Dice:
"Rubia y con 25 kilos menos,
a seis meses de ser mamá,
revela el secreto de su nueva figura
y el plan de casarse con Pedro
por segunda vez
antes de tener su tercer hijo.
Por qué decidió dedicarse
full time a la familia
y cómo alimenta la pasión en la pareja".
¿Qué ideas hay detrás de esto?
Para ser ama de casa
hay que usar tacos y pollera.
Hay que tener una mano
como escondiendo el rollo.
Hay que casarse más de una vez
con la misma persona.
Hay que elegir si ser ama de casa
o ser profesional.
¿Por qué es importante,
inmediatamente después de ser madre,
bajar de peso y teñirse de rubio?
El juego funciona así.
Mi idea es que Uds.
lo hagan cuando salgan.
Yo creo que preguntarnos es fundamental,
porque la comediante que hace un chiste
reforzando que la mujer debe ser flaca
lo hace sin darse cuenta de que
la premisa "la mujer debe ser flaca"
la bombardeó desde
todos los rincones de su vida.
Y tenemos que tomar consciencia de esto.
Hay comediantes que te presentan como
"la bella", "la dama", "la diosa"
y lo hacen con la mejor intención.
Lo hacen como diciendo:
"Pido un fuerte aplauso".
Usan esas categorías como:
"¡Dale, vos podés! ¡Confío en vos!
¿Y cómo podrían categorías así
cooperar con la risa?
Tenemos que tomar consciencia
de esto, en el humor,
y en todos los niveles de la vida.
Por favor, les pido que, cuando salgan,
hagan este juego.
Tal vez me odien un poquitito,
porque preguntarse es muy difícil,
además de molesto.
Es difícil, porque cada vez
que hacemos una pregunta,
inevitablemente, estamos buscando
una respuesta.
Pero, si Uds. hacen este juego,
y se van, y me odian un poquitito,
yo voy a estar contenta,
porque iniciamos el camino
a una sociedad más igualitaria,
más justa y, sobre todo, una sociedad
que se ría de mejores cosas
que ser "la diosa del stand up".
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)